"Mona mittendrin - bei Alkoholikern",
viele Reaktionen,
viele Leute sahen die Sendung.
Sybille, Felix, Liz,
ihr wart vorher "normale" Menschen.
jetzt wissen alle, die euch sehen,
dass ihr ein Alkoholproblem habt.
Welche Reaktionen
habt ihr nach der Sendung erlebt?
Die persönlichen Reaktionen
waren nur positiv.
Ein Freund hat mich angerufen
und gesagt:
"Ich habe den Trailer gesehen,
man sieht dich ja!"
Das wusste er nicht,
er dachte, ich bleibe anonym.
Ich wollte das
von Anfang an so machen.
Ich musste so viel lügen,
als ich noch getrunken habe.
Das ist auch ein Grund,
einfach mal reinen Tisch zu machen.
Es kamen auch Reaktionen wie:
"Schön, dass diese Krankheit
ein Gesicht bekommt."
Das man weiss,
dass auch normale
Menschen betroffen sein können.
Aber ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass es so viele Reaktionen gibt.
V.a. positive.
Mein Enkel schrieb mir:
"Ich bin mega stolz auf dich, Nani."
Eine Enkelin schrieb mir,
ich solle allen sagen,
es sei schlimm,
was wir alles erleben mussten.
Wir drei.
Das wird ja in meiner Familie
diskutiert.
Aber alle fünf Enkelkinder sagten,
sie hätten das wirkliche Ausmass,
wie es genau gewesen war,
nicht gekannt.
Deine Familie hat durch die Sendung
also noch Neues erfahren
über jene Zeit,
in der du so viel getrunken hast.
Ja.
Bei dir gibt es einen Grund,
weshalb du dein Gesicht nicht zeigst:
Eine deiner Töchter möchte das nicht.
Warum?
Sie will nicht,
dass sie mit mir unterwegs ist,
und die Leute dann sagen:
"Schau, das ist ja ihre Mutter,
die hat ja so gesoffen."
Ich habe euch ein paar ...
Wir haben
so viele Kommentare erhalten.
Ich habe euch einige ausgedruckt.
Damit ihr einen Eindruck davon habt,
was die Zuschauer/-innen, die User,
alles geschrieben haben.
Am meisten Kommentare bekamen wir
von Menschen, deren Eltern tranken.
Ganz krasse Geschichten,
die mich sehr bewegten.
Oder auch von Partnerinnen
und Partnern.
Rachel schreibt z.B.: "Mein Vater."
"Ich wuchs mit Alkoholismus auf.
Ich war immer in Angst."
Eine Frau, die jede Woche
panisch zu Hause wartete,
ob es der Vater nach Hause schafft,
ohne einen Unfall zu bauen.
Sobald er da war, schloss sie sich
ein, um nicht geschlagen zu werden.
Rosi schreibt, als Kind mag man
seine Eltern, man möchte helfen,
man will, dass sich etwas ändert.
Es sei schlimm, zuzuschauen,
wie sich jemand kaputt macht.
Viele haben auch ...
Du, Liz,
hast von deinen Kindern erzählt.
Du hattest drei kleine Kinder
während der Zeit,
in der du richtig viel trankst.
Eine Frau schrieb,
ihre Mutter sei auch Alkoholikerin
und sie wollte sie immer verstehen.
Sie wollte verstehen, was in ihr
vorging, wenn sie sie schickte,
um Alkohol zu kaufen oder sie sie
betrunken ins Bett brachten.
Was geht in einem vor als Mutter?
Kann ich dich das fragen?
Was würdest du da antworten?
Wenn man so extrem betrunken ist,
sind diese Gefühle tot.
Diese Gefühle
kommen erst am nächsten Tag.
Ich hatte oft einen Filmriss.
Ich wusste vieles nicht mehr.
Aber wenn die Kinder mir das sagten,
entstand so ein Schamgefühl ...
Das kann man gar nicht beschreiben.
Man will einfach
in einem Loch verschwinden.
Das löst dann auch
Alkoholdepressionen aus.
Aus den Schuldgefühlen heraus.
Es ist eine Katastrophe.
Es ist für die Kinder extrem schlimm.
Aber auch für mich als Mutter.
Man sieht die Kinder
nicht mehr als seine Kinder,
sieht nicht, was man ihnen antut.
Die Sucht, die man stillen muss,
ist ein innerer Zwang.
Dem kann man nicht widerstehen.
Es ist eigentlich paradox.
Ich als Mutter liebe meine Kinder.
Ich hätte alles
für meine Kinder gegeben.
Und doch schaffte ich es
elf Jahre lang nicht.
Ich fragte eine Frau,
die mir schrieb,
wer sie in dieser Zeit unterstützte.
Sie schrieb: niemand.
Das ist ja richtig krass.
Was kann, was muss man als Angehö-
rige machen, wo kann man Hilfe holen?
Man hört ja auch, dass Alkoholismus
eine Familienkrankheit ist.
Die Betroffenen leiden auch.
Sie werden wahrscheinlich
auch krank dadurch.
Sie brauchen auch
professionelle Hilfe.
Es gibt Selbsthilfegruppen,
die sich darum kümmern,
aber auch gute Psychologen
und Psychiater, die helfen können.
Wichtig ist,
dass sich diese Menschen Hilfe holen.
- Warum ist es so schwierig?
- Es ist die Scham.
Aber man trinkt ja selbst gar nicht.
Aber mein Partner oder meine Part-
nerin oder ein Elternteil trinkt.
Und das jemandem mitzuteilen,
ist extrem schwierig.
Man schämt sich extrem.
Meine Kinder schämten sich für mich.
Meine Schwester schämte sich - alle.
Meine Mutter, die ganze Familie.
Das geht bei allen wie ein
roter Faden durch ihr Leben,
wenn jemand in der Familie trinkt.
Die Gesellschaft denkt noch,
es sei Willensschwäche,
ein schlechter Charakter.
Du hast das im Film so klar
und deutlich gesagt, Mona:
Es ist eine Krankheit.
Ich hatte manchmal ...
... zwei Gesichter.
Zwei Felix.
Wenn ich nüchtern war
und wenn ich betrunken war.
Ich hatte ein scheussliches Gesicht.
Allerdings. Ich hatte auch
andere zwei Gesichter.
Ohne Alkohol, vor dem Trinken
habe ich mir gefallen,
wenn ich in den Spiegel schaute.
Und wenn ich mich 3 Std. später
anschaute, dachte ich:
"Nein, das bin ich nicht mehr."
Ohne, dass ich ...
Das Make-up stimmte noch.
Aber ich war so ...
Ich strahlte etwas Kaputtes aus.
Es war in meinen Augen,
um meinen Mund.
Und ich konnte nichts dagegen tun.
Auch wenn ich lächelte,
sah es scheisse kaputt aus.
Ab einem gewissen Stadium schaute ich
mich nicht mehr im Spiegel an.
Viele Menschen gaben die Rückmeldung,
dass die Sendung grossartig war,
dass sie sich aber mehr Perspektiven
von Angehörigen gewünscht hätten.
Dein Mann Oliver
setzte sich hin und erzählte -
wie er es erlebte bzw. nicht erlebte.
Er stand dazu,
dass er es gar nicht merkte.
Welche Reaktionen erhielt er?
Er hat mir von durchwegs
positiven Reaktionen erzählt.
V.a. aus unserem Freundeskreis.
Ich sehe hier auch diesen Kommentar -
den habe ich schon gelesen -
von einem Herrn der schreibt:
Es ist einerseits schwer vorstellbar,
andererseits versteckte ich es gut.
Im Vorfeld der Sendung thematisierten
wir das auch zu zweit wieder einmal.
Das ist ja nicht immer
ein Thema bei uns.
Wir haben da auch offener
darüber gesprochen.
Ich dachte mir auch:
Für viele Leute
wird es unverständlich sein.
Aber es ist nicht so unverständlich.
Ich erhielt eine ähnliche Reaktion.
Ein Arbeitskollege
schrieb mir in einer Mail,
"Wir haben zehn Jahre lang
sehr eng zusammengearbeitet."
"Und ich habe nie etwas bemerkt."
Das hat damit zu tun,
dass man versucht, sich abzuschotten.
Man versucht, es zu verheimlichen.
Man geht vielleicht
morgens zweimal duschen,
oder isst tonnenweise Süssigkeiten,
die nach Menthol schmecken,
um es zu verbergen.
Man schaut,
dass man keinen nahen Kontakt hat.
Damit man nicht merkt,
dass man wieder getrunken hat.
Du verstehst also sogar, dass viele
Menschen das nicht bemerken?
Ja.
Man wollte ja auch,
dass sie es nicht bemerken.
Denn man hätte sich geschämt.
Sybille,
ich verstehe deinen Mann sehr gut.
Wir können so gut lügen.
Wenn ich rumblödelte,
sagte ich jeweils:
"Ich habe ein Engagement am
Schauspielhaus für fünf Jahre,
den Vertrag
erneuere ich immer wieder."
Der Alkoholiker ist ein Schauspieler.
Ich hatte einen extremen
Parfümverschleiss.
Und den kleinen Odolspray
hatte ich in allen Taschen.
Man versucht überall ...
Oder Spitzwegerich-Bonbons -
Jahre später sahen die Kinder
so eine Schachtel und meinten:
"Mami, das sind die Bonbons,
die du so mochtest."
Schau, Mona,
ich habe einen guten Kommentar.
Diesen hier finde ich auch gut,
er geht in die gleiche Richtung.
Ich finde es nicht schlimm, dass
alle Alkohol trinken, das dürfen,
es im Griff haben, sondern:
Es ist wirklich mühsam,
wenn man sich erklären muss,
weil man kein Alkohol trinkt.
Das sollte nicht mehr so sein.
Jeder soll das machen, wie er will.
Ohne dass man lügen muss.
"Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es so viele Alkoholiker gibt."
- Das schrieb jemand?
- Ja.
Die Dunkelziffer ist sehr hoch.
Das hat einerseits
auch mit der Scham zu tun,
dass man zugibt,
ein Problem zu haben.
Und andererseits: Bis man merkt,
dass man ein Problem hat,
schiebt man das Problem
lange vor sich hin.
Man trinkt vielleicht
ein bisschen viel.
Aber dass man wirklich
alkoholkrank ist,
wird den wenigsten bewusst.
Einen Kommentar
fand ich sehr interessant.
Ein Mann, der schrieb,
seiner Meinung nach,
müsse zuerst etwas richtig Krasses
passieren,
man müsse richtig hinfallen,
bis man sich eingestehen kann:
"Ich habe ein Problem."
- Seht ihr das ähnlich?
- Ja, das ist so.
Der persönliche Tiefpunkt
ist ja nicht bei jedem derselbe.
Aber alle, die ich kenne,
die trocken wurden, erreichten den.
Dieser Punkt liegt tief.
Es funktioniert ja immer noch
so mit knapper Not.
Ich habe es immer hingekriegt -
mit Ausreden, mit Lügen,
mit Vertuschen, aber irgendwann
blättert das alles ab.
Bei mir - und bei euch allen -
war das erst dann,
als wir ganz unten waren,
keine Chance mehr hatten.
Darum finde ich es so wichtig,
dass man darauf angesprochen wird,
dass der Druck da ist.
Sonst passiert nichts.
Es ist ziemlich einfach.
Das war eine andere Frage,
die viele stellten.
Wir als Angehörige, als Gesellschaft,
sollen wir es ansprechen oder nicht?
Eine Frau schrieb, ihr Vater
sei Alkoholiker gewesen.
Sie haben es immer angesprochen -
und es gab immer Streit.
Es sei so mühsam gewesen -
darum lässt man die Betroffenen
vielleicht irgendwann im Stich,
weil man diesen Konflikt
nicht immer will.
Aber du sagst,
diesen Druck muss man ausüben?
Das kann bis zur Trennung führen.
Dass der Vater oder die Mutter
gehen muss.
Das kann ein nächster Schritt sein.
Das ist dann dieser Tiefpunkt
für die betroffene Person.
Wenn es nicht mehr anders geht.
Solange niemand etwas sagt,
kann man fröhlich weiter saufen.
Solange meine Kinder
nichts gesagt haben,
mir kein schlechtes Gewissen
gemacht haben,
musste ich ja nichts verändern.
Einen Kommentar
möchte ich noch vorlesen.
Melina bedankte sich auf Instagram,
sie schrieb:
Schön. Ja.
Bei mir hat es funktioniert.
Vielen Dank euch allen.
Wenn es etwas gibt zu diesem Thema,
das euch wichtig ist -
wir sind gespannt, wir lesen es gerne
in der Kommentarspalte.
Den Film "Mona mittendrin - bei
Alkoholikern" findet ihr hier.
Abonniert diesen Kanal, dann bleibt
ihr auf dem Laufenden. Vielen Dank.